I also think for the Republican party I
think this is important Hispanics are
trending Republican right and I think it
why are why is that happening in part
because Democrats don't know how to
speak to them right they either call
them latinx
come on which does not resonate when you
go macro right when you and then when
you go nuanced you call them a San
Antonio taco right so so they don't get
the macro branding they don't get the
nuanced Brandy and I think this is an
awesome opportunity for Republicans to
say hey we respect you
um we know you want to be Americans we
know you're law abiding we know that you
believe in family
um and and you want to you know you
believe in the family unit as a means of
trying to get people to be successful in
education these are all of the things
that Republicans always talk about
foreign
odds do you feel like you are with the
current Administration
well I think we're at odds on on a lot
of issues look we're in odds on
government spending right they've
they've created this inflation now in
California they're giving thousand
dollars in anti-inflation which is going
to create more inflation so they've
experience they always raise the taxes
and then they give you your money back
and you're supposed to thank them for it
exactly and by the way it just creates
inflation right right so you've got more
inflation so you've got a you know
dysfunctional foreign policy you know
disastrous retreat in Afghanistan
conventional war in Ukraine which
obviously this Administration wasn't
able to avoid
um you know you've got
um this oil situation in in in in the
entire world right where you have oil
prices that are dependent on on foreign
uh you know producers uh the dependency
of Europe on Russia you've got South
America going socialist more and more in
the US having no coherent policy on that
um you know we have systematically
ignored Cuba's role as the head of the
snake in exporting its only commodity
which is communism and doing it very
effectively because they were trained by
the Russians in the 1970s and and and
you know their supply chain issues I
mean they have really not confronted
successfully in my opinion any of the
macro issues that are generational uh in
nature that are going to set up this
country for Success where are you at on
the on the immigration stuff generally
obviously we had this big thing with the
Martha's Vineyard sure that whole thing
um I don't even really know actually how
the city falls on when people just show
up here and all that stuff yeah look I
mean we're a city of immigrants right
um mostly legal immigrants frankly um
because you know Cubans had a favorable
immigration policy called you know web
foot dry foot and what preceded it so
you were able to get a Asylum
essentially automatically I just don't
think we're having a very coherent
conversation about it you know on both
sides right I think uh when you look at
a city like Miami we have 1.4
unemployment that's awesome until you
want to start until you want to start a
small business and then you can't find
employees yeah right so the beauty of us
of America versus China for example
people is we both have declining birth
rates and the difference is nobody wants
to go to China everybody wants to come
here so I think that's an opportunity if
we have a conversation that benefits the
U.S right as opposed to just a border
conversation right and I think that's
where I hope the future of this
conversation goes because this is an
unresolved issue that is not it reminds
me of world war one trench warfare
everybody's sort of in their side just
gonna poke up they get back in and then
you know in a year they maybe move four
inches right so there's just no coherent
discussion on it so so what do we do in
Miami like what's the policy if somehow
illegals get here yeah I'm not even sure
where the Martha's Vineyard one started
or how they ended up roughly here yeah
but what is the city's policy on well we
don't we don't we're not ice right yeah
so so we don't have a formal role yeah
um so that's an ice issue right the
federal government immigrations customer
Enforcement issue as to whether or not
um how they detain people and and what
they do with them once they're detained
so we don't have a role in that we don't
we don't get in their way either you
know we sort of let them do their job
and support them uh if and when
necessary but um you know again part of
what makes us special is our diversity
right and our inclusion in terms of a
variety of different people that come
from a variety of different backgrounds
and it's what makes us who we are so I
also think for the Republican party I
think this is important Hispanics are
trending Republican right and I think it
why why is that happening in part
because Democrats don't know how to
speak to them right they either call
them latinx
come on which does not resonate when you
go macro right when you and then when
you go nuanced you call them a San
Antonio taco right so so they don't get
the macro branding they don't get the
nuanced Brandy and I think this is an
awesome opportunity for Republicans to
say hey we respect you
um we know you want to be Americans we
know you're law abiding we know that you
believe in family
um and and you want to you know you
believe in the family unit as a means of
trying to get people to be successful in
education these are all of the things
that Republicans always talk about right
so um you know there's a great
opportunity there to lean into that and
not be worried that if you know
something happens on the immigration
front it's going to be damaging to
Republicans it actually might be very
beneficial you mean you're telling me
that Latinos just like everyone else
care about more than one issue they do
isn't that why and they care about our
country very bizarre let me ask you one
that actually look at how many southern
Texas border in Congressional races no
it's incredible Republican women that
are going to hopefully sweep uh three
Congressional race including one I think
they hadn't held for 150 years Myra
Flores and she's the one that then the
New York Times ran the article uh what
was it the the Latino face of the new
right or something or the alt-right
something insane let me ask you one
about that I saw some of my guys uh
giving you some crap for which is some
of the gun buyback stuff and this thing
so I saw my more conservative side it's
coming for guns he's a Democrat
something like that so I allow you to
clean it up however well first of all I
think people that like you generally
that live in this city anything and I
think I'll tell you this
um
let's see how I put this sort of a
little bit delicately right there's a
lot of jocking going on right now and
there's a lot of surrogates that are
doing a lot of things to try to uh build
people up and tear people down you know
kill them in the crib type of thing
there's a lot of that happening with me
as my profile gets bigger as I get um
talked about in more prominent circles
it's more like hey let's try to Brand
him as a certain thing right and there's
a lot of that happening with me
um but you know gun buyback is something
that the city's been doing forever right
and it's not about
um you know being pro-gon or anything
I'm I'm firmly pro-second Amendment I'm
a gun owner and an incredibly Pro police
I think really more it's more for you
know what happens oftentimes is like a
widow right whose husband passes and and
the husband was an avid gun collector
and they have 20 30 guns at home and
they're afraid that if somebody breaks
in they're gonna steal the guns and kill
them or hurt somebody else so they just
don't feel safe with the guns at home
and they prefer to sell it these you
know oftentimes are elderly people who
are living on fixed income right and
they get you know we have have like uh
what do you call it a coupon so we give
them or you know I forget what they're
called uh sort of a gift cards that we
give them right and so we'll give them
gift cards to Publix or gift cards to
Target or whatever and they'd rather
have you know fifteen hundred dollars in
gift cards to Target than 20 guns that
they don't know what they're doing with
right in their own home so that's that's
the that's the prototypical scenario so
it's not like we want to take guns off
the street in that sense or we want
people not to it's completely voluntary
right so people want to do it they do it
if they don't want to do it they don't
have to do it do we even have a gun
problem I mean is there are there
shootings here really like so so that
that's the other thing is that you know
in this in this conversation about gun
violence you know people it's such a
myopic conversation right we don't talk
about the fact that uh in Miami for
example we have we were ranked the
happiest city in America the healthiest
city in America with 1.4 unemployment
and increasing funding for police
departments so it turns out if you have
more police officers Happy People
healthy people and people that are
working guess what they're not killing
other people right so that's the formula
for six the happiness and by the way
that has nothing to do with whether they
own a gun or don't own a gun that has to
do with their frame of mind it has to do
with where they what they are in life
and I often said look you know if
somebody wants to hurt somebody there
are unfortunately a multitude of ways
that that can happen and so we've got to
look at the root cause of why people
feel compelled to do X and where we're
missing and I think that that gets lost
in the discussion a lot if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell